[Música]
semana de cumbre sin reuniones y de toma
de decisiones alemania fue la sede de la
cumbre del g7 que reúne a las economías
más grandes y más poderosas del mundo y
madrid en españa' fue la sede de la
cumbre de los países integrantes de la
otan
ambos encuentros más o menos contaron
con algunos asistentes en común pero
tuvieron similitudes en cuanto a los
temas de la agenda cerraron filas en
torno a las sanciones y a ese cerco
económico que quieren establecer contra
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
también hubo unanimidad en cuanto a
mantener la ayuda económica para ucrania
para que continúe en su resistencia
contra las tropas rusas que han invadido
principalmente las zonas de el este de
ucrania también se habló de inseguridad
alimentaria también se habló del papel
de china del cambio climático y del
fortalecimiento de la presencia de
europa o del mundo occidental en
territorios puntuales como el este de
europa a través de el aumento del número
de tropas
pues muy bien en esta edición del debate
de france 24 vamos a hablar para este
cierre de semana de el análisis de los
principales puntos y las conclusiones
que nos dejaron este par de encuentros
importantes que tuvieron lugar allí en
europa y para ello hemos invitado a anna
del paso ellas analista internacional y
profesora de la universidad complutense
de madrid
ella se encuentra en este momento en
ponferrada y desde la capital española
se conecta a esta conversación fernando
coche él es analista de inteligencia y
seguridad internacional les recuerdo
también que ustedes hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y todos sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter en instagram y en facebook en
donde no se encuentran como france24
bajo ese arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 en youtube también
pueden seguir nuestra señal en streaming
y también los invito para que escuchen
el podcast de nuestro programa todo
nuestro contenido ya está disponible en
plataformas como app el podcast spotify
dice y un in pues entonces sana y
fernando les doy la bienvenida al
programa vamos a comenzar entonces
analizando primero los puntos clave de
la cumbre del g7 que como ya lo dije
tuvo lugar en los alpes bávaros en el
sur de alemania entre los puntos
importantes pues estaba mencionando la
ayuda para ucrania
cuanto tiempo sea necesario así lo
dijeron allí en esta cumbre y también se
suma a esta agenda temas de la seguridad
alimentaria del cambio climático en el
siguiente reportaje hacemos un breve
resumen de lo que fue este encuentro así
en alemania veamos
el g7 busca resolver las consecuencias
de la guerra en ucrania los líderes de
las democracias más ricas del mundo
abordaron en un castillo de los alpes
bávaros temas relacionados con la crisis
medioambiental la economía global la
salud las exportaciones y las cadenas de
suministro entre otros una de las
grandes conclusiones fue la posibilidad
de prohibir el transporte de petróleo
ruso que se venda por encima de un
determinado precio una decisión que
aumenta la presión occidental sobre
rusia y busca agotar las arcas de moscú
aumentaremos nuestra vigilancia ante las
amenazas incluida la conversión
económica que pretende socavar la
seguridad y estabilidad mundial para
ello buscaremos una mayor cooperación y
exploraremos mecanismos para mejorar la
evaluación la preparación la disuasión y
la respuesta a dichos riesgos
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que las naciones del grupo prohibir a
las importaciones de oro provenientes de
rusia italia propuso la posibilidad de
limitar el precio del gas rusos mientras
francia pidió que se limiten los precios
de todas las ventas de energía
claramente lo que sale de nuestras
discusiones y conclusiones no es que
occidente esté opuesto al resto del
mundo sino unido en la paz en contra de
la guerra el océano puede y no va a
ganar y por lo tanto nuestro apoyo a
ucrania en nuestras sanciones contra
rusia van a continuar durante el tiempo
que sea necesario y con la intensidad
que sean necesarias el g7 también
ayudará en la financiación de las
necesidades inmediatas de ucrania así
como la reconstrucción de su economía a
largo plazo y aunque el grupo de los
siete planea destinar 4500 millones de
dólares a la lucha contra el hambre en
el mundo el programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu aseguró que se
necesitarán como mínimo 22 mil 200
millones de dólares este año para
afrontar lo que han denominado la peor
crisis de hambre en una generación
bueno pues hoy pasó entonces a nuestros
invitados que se encuentran en españa
anna bienvenida quiero comenzar
preguntándole por sus impresiones de
esta cumbre del g7 en alemania cerraron
filas estas siete economías las más
poderosas del mundo en torno al tema en
común y es ese cerco económico al
presidente ruso vladimir putin y a la
economía rusa
bueno esta fue una antesala de lo que
sobre todo la parte de la ética
económica y bueno también total temas de
la cob y de el tema de salud que es
importantísimo porque seguimos en
pandemia y temas de
tecnológicos y sobre todo de recursos de
energéticos y alimentaria que si no
evitamos el problema con el trigo y se
batan de ucrania pues que es el máximo
exportador y productor del trigo y asia
y exportador hacia áfrica pues la crisis
alimentaria y los precios pueden pueden
repercutir realmente y sobre todo a
[Música]
de forma directa áfrica
uno de los puntos más importantes que yo
veo que se ha puesto sobre la mesa y en
un contacto y sonante es que han dicho
que están
dispuestas a conceder o han prometido o
prestado prestado en ayuda humanitaria
28 mil millones de euros esto es una
cifra
que es bastante superior de la que
estaba prevista y
gran parte de ella va a ir destinada a
la recuperación
de la reestructuración de ucrania que ya
se ha comprometido a realizarla en el
posconflicto
por otra parte
van a cerrar están endureciendo
las puertas a rusia pero esto a mí me
preocupa un poco porque aunque en esta
cumbre estaba en día presente
sigue teniendo el apoyo de los brics los
cinco países emergentes que son brasil
india
brasil india china rusia bueno rusia y
sudáfrica entonces lo que no va a
conseguir por un lado lo consigue por
otro es decir rusia sigue estando
asegurado en divisas exportación e
importación
y fernando también le doy la bienvenida
al programa su opinión su perspectiva
sobre este encuentro del g7 que tal vez
da la impresión que este pulso entre
occidente digámoslo así o estas siete
economías más importantes del mundo
contra rusia pues prácticamente ya está
entrando en un punto que es
completamente irreversible se tomaron
decisiones importantes para seguir
haciéndole cerco a la federación rusa
si así es como ha dicho muy bien mi
compañera anna la bloqueo hacia a rusia
lo que está haciendo es intentar
recuperar el peso estratégico
fundamentalmente de la unión europea
como bloque económico bloque de
importancia geopolítica y el problema
reside en que hay otras perspectivas hay
otros grupos de presión que ya están por
sí mismos también estableciendo una
contramedida al bloqueo con rusia china
no ha podido cumplir sus promesas que se
hicieron para evitar el bloqueo con
europa precisamente por una cuestión de
pandémica de
kobe no pero ahora que ha salido ya de
esa cuestión se ha comprometido hasta
2035 a aumentar entre 26 y 31 por ciento
anual de las importaciones de energía
hasta el 2035 por parte de rusia en el
caso de otros países que no se han
nombrado y que sin embargo están detrás
de un control geopolítico de la zona nos
encontramos por ejemplo el control
irán que ejerce una posición dominante
en todo lo que es oriente medio y que
está enfrentado a los intereses de eeuu
sin embargo hemos visto que este eje 7
como ha ocurrido también luego la cumbre
de la otan ha optado una estrategia de
modificar las perspectivas de lo que es
un amigo lo que es un enemigo volvemos
una guerra de bloques en el que incluso
eeuu está negociando con el propio irán
está negociando con con venezuela para
la compra de combustible y
fortalecimiento de la cadena del
diésel no del gasóleo por decirlo de
buena manera rotor de sólido pesado que
es el p53 para los aviones entonces
están bloqueando los pero no tanto
entonces se está intentando recuperar
una unidad en el g7 para evitar por
ejemplo el caso de india que se alinee
cosas que no van a conseguir con y china
para que se incorpore a esa evolución
del comercio de la asean y controlen
dentro de tres años dos tercios de la
economía del mundo en asia central ya
sea en oriente medio también y entabló
que es
este móvil fernando continuo con usted
hacemos la ronda a la inversa
precisamente el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden insistió en la unidad
para hacer frente a los retos que nos
estamos enfrentando son las palabras
textuales del presidente de eeuu que tan
sólido se muestra el g7 después de esta
reunión y cuál puede ser la respuesta de
rusia porque usted lo ha mencionado eeuu
está tratando de acercarse por intereses
en los hidrocarburos a venezuela está
tratando de negociar con irán que son
países que son un poco más alineados con
moscú con quien se puede aliar rusia más
allá de china que es un país que ha
tratado de no meterse en este tema del
conflicto de la guerra en ucrania y ya
lo vamos a analizar más adelante el
papel que tiene china en todo esto
pues rusia ya está alineada con por otra
parte con venezuela también está
alineada con brasil está alineada con
argelia que sus administradores de gas
muy importante para europa y con el que
en ese momento la europea en algún que
otro conflicto y también españa está
alineada con sudáfrica pero mucho más
importante que todo eso que está aliado
con todas las economías subsidiarias que
tiene china bajo su mandato próximo van
a manera no es todo todo hacia
prácticamente y cuando la india entre a
establecer un aliado tradicional de eeuu
cuando la india entre se verá realmente
cuál es el apoyo que tiene en el fondo
lo que estamos viendo es nada más que
una partida de ajedrez en la que eeuu va
a intentar de nuevo por cuarta vez en su
historia recuperar el peso perdido
el punto vista geoestratégico y hablemos
de la anglósfera en todo un gran bretaña
de alianza los cinco ojos en temas de
inteligencia por ejemplo aunque usen
madre civil inteligencia para no
quedarse atrás pero
hasta los informes algunos no prometo
los informes establecen que a pesar de
la unión el g7 a pesar de la economía
del g7 a pesar de que eeuu de nuevo otra
vez nueve horas subordinar los intereses
de europa a sus intereses geopolíticos
no va a ser suficiente como para que
china no le gane la carrera y que
digamos la parte para entendernos
oriental del mundo
esté apoyando a china y por tanto
indirectamente a rusia y dentro de 45
años así lo ha dicho
brink en la otan si las cosas van bien
dentro de 45 años nos volveremos a dicho
nos volvemos a sentar con rusia para
pactar los siguientes acuerdos por tanto
ya es terminando en un futuro en el que
rusia gane o pierda eso es lo menos
importante en este caso volver a ser un
actor comerciante ya que usted menciona
china quiero preguntarle a anna por esas
declaraciones que hizo el primer
ministro japonés en el marco de este
encuentro el ministro kishida habló de
esa indivisibilidad
y la seguridad de europa y la seguridad
del indo pacífico se abre aquí como un
nuevo frente a un nuevo escenario
estábamos viendo este este grupo
moviéndose muy libremente digámoslo así
por el escenario europeo pero ahora
entra este escenario de indochina
precisamente para contrarrestar el peso
de lo que está ejerciendo china en esta
zona de influencia como pueden ser estas
repercusiones que pueda recibir el
gobierno chino este país precisamente
por por esa crítica tan grande que se le
hace a nivel internacional por no haber
tomado una posición clara frente al
conflicto en ucrania que es lo que le
cobra occidente a beijing bueno lo que
están haciendo es posicionarse frente a
una amenaza de china en taiwán entonces
están tomando posiciones igual que se
está despoblando
australia nueva zelanda etc pero el
ejército
ha estado invitado indonesia india
senegal y vietnam
esto es bastante significativo que
cuatro países
tres son asiáticos entonces
es decir
en los tres blancos que son el este y no
sólo es rusia es todo el este hacia
hacia el sur del sahel y el ártico
entonces
existía precisamente a la reunión que
lindo es lindo asia y fue muy
interesante porque lo que lo que está
haciendo rusia son tomar posiciones
desde el 2004 empezó a diseñar su
posición de asia de asia hacia ucrania
luego veremos
[Música]
bielorrusia a nivel de rusia aquí
kaliningrado y china hará lo mismo no es
a corto plazo porque china trabaja a
medio y largo plazo
y veremos que en 10 20 años bueno diez o
quince años china empezará a hacer sus
maniobras sobre taiwán y sobre las islas
gracias
[Música]
bueno no son cortoplacistas es decir
nosotros tenemos que tiene la manía de
manía de hacerlas de ser visiones
cortoplacistas hacia y rusia es distinto
lo miran a más largo plazo fernando su
opinión sobre este tema sobre estos
reclamos que le están haciendo a china y
esta especie de factura que le están
cobrando a china por su papel en o por
esta falta de papel protagonismo
oposición en la guerra en ucrania
bueno realmente es una guerra que a
pesar de los esfuerzos está teniendo
tiene dos polos muy importantes ella ha
apuntado también nuestra compañera
primero el china mira a largo plazo a
sus planes están en torno a 15 20 30
años vista y a ellos no les importa
perder ahora un proceso de negociación
cuando lo van a ganar en cuestión de
10-15 años mientras que estamos viendo
que de nuevo otra vez el g7 y esa
amenaza en el indo-pacífico no es una
amenaza hacia europa aunque pueda ser un
turista comercial no es una amenaza
militar hacia europa ni económica sólo
hacia europa es básicamente una amenaza
a los intereses de eeuu y quedan europa
subordinado a los mismos y todo lo que
se llama la anglósfera es decir gran
bretaña eeuu australia oa zelanda e
indirectamente también a japón que se
incorpora casualmente dentro de la
alianza económica de europa y eeuu pero
también está incorporada dentro de la
alianza económica que china propuesta
propuesto para toda asia en la que
también está australia por tanto un poco
de eseverri de la palabra un poco de
esquizofrenia en estos intereses
cruzados los que al mi modo de ver
haciendo prospectiva chinas lleva las de
ganar y muchas cosas tienen que ocurrir
para que china no gane al menos en diez
de las 35 bebidas implantado y ya está
ganando en cuatro
este tema lo voy a ampliar ahora que
hablemos de la reunión de la otan para
ir cerrando el tema del g7 queda sobre
la mesa un tema importante y es esas
declaraciones del gobierno italiano de
tratar de reducir la dependencia del gas
ruso vuelve y queda otra vez europa
mostrando esa vulnerabilidad energética
que tiene ante el suministro ruso no
comprarle oro a rusia aumentar ese veto
a la producción de petróleo en la unión
europea dijo que se muestra confiada en
que dentro del marco del g7 se puedan
dar algunas soluciones precisamente para
cortar esos nexos
energéticos y económicos que tienen
entre moscú y bruselas y los es que
componen el g7 que en este caso pues el
más destacado sería alemania dentro de
la unión europea francia e italia su
perspectiva fernando de este tema que
tanto preocupa a europa
pues es un complicado primero estamos
volviendo a una reindustrialización
energética de combustibles fósiles
incluso en países que ya habían
prácticamente abandonado como es
alemania incluso partido verde alemán ha
votado por la red carbonización de su
país de alemania austria vuelve a mirar
hacia energías no renovables italia ha
abierto una cuenta en rublos para seguir
comprando por países intermediarios
petróleo y gas a esta a rusia por tanto
la dependencia energética que tenemos
que seguimos teniendo y que hoy en día
sigue teniendo es altísima y el tiempo
que se requiere para obtener la
dependencia se requiere en torno a 5 a 8
años para lograr una auténtica
independencia de ccoo energética en 58
años es mucho tiempo
por tanto el gas que está comprando
ahora que por cierto en la mitad de los
países europeos es gas ilegal porque
proviene de estados unidos por medio del
fracking nos llevaría a también un
conflicto en el punto vista
medioambiental pero la economía pasa por
delante del medio ambiente en este caso
y el g7 está intentando re posicionarse
estratégicamente a medio el plazo para
sobrevivir ni siquiera para ganar
problemas para ser los segundos en la
carrera y no ser los 42 quintos anna
puntualmente su perspectiva sobre este
tema a su opinar y bueno a ver el
estándar la energía eólica la solar
hidráulica la geométrica mareomotrices
que mirando aquí un montones de energías
que tienen que ser
la alternativa a los fósiles y al
petróleo bueno al gas también pero el
problema está en que nosotros por
ejemplo españa y francia bueno es 90%
nuclear aunque le compra gas a españa
pero
en nosotros
alemania
[Música]
pese a que uno de sus miembros uno de
los partidos de uno de los partidos de
gobierno es de ser partido verde pues
vuelve otra vez a las minas de carbón
que
son altamente
[Música]
en contaminantes contaminantes es un
poco contradictorio y va a decir pero en
el caso de españa tenemos un problema
porque todas estas logísticas e
infraestructuras del carbón las hemos
desmantelado y ya son inservibles
entonces
tenemos una gran un gran parque eólico y
dirigida a comprar pero como decía mi
compañero pues para hacerlo productivo y
rentable se tiene que ir a los 15 años
por lo que han dicho los declarados
entonces lo único que nos queda es la
dependencia a argelia y marruecos a
europa ya tiene acordados acordados y
cerrados los contratos con argelia el
único crédito se ha quedado fuera de
españa por los conflictos políticos
diplomáticos
bueno pues doy por terminado este tema
del g7 sé que hay más aristas para
analizar pero debo también hablar sobre
el tema de la otan esta cumbre dejó como
conclusión el concepto estratégico de
madrid que es el plan de acción que va a
tener esta alianza para los próximos
años además también cierra esta cumbre
de la otan en madrid con dos nuevos
integrantes porque suecia y finlandia
después de muchas discrepancias con
turquía fueran oficialmente invitados
para ser parte de esta
alianza eso sí ankara fue muy claro en
decir que si no cumplen los compromisos
no los dejara entrar también acordaron
un mayor despliegue de tropas mayor
desarrollo tecnológico y también la
presencia en el lindo pacífico otro tema
que se venía hablando en el g7 lo
resumimos en el siguiente reporte
preparado por la redacción de france 24
veamos
mientras finlandia y suecia reciben la
bienvenida a la otan rusia y china-
ahora se consideran una amenaza para la
misma así quedó definido en el nuevo
concepto estratégico que marcará la hoja
de ruta de la alianza para los próximos
10 años en una decisión militar
histórica que no se registraba desde la
guerra fría la organización acordó
reforzar el flanco oriental con 300.000
tropas de cara a la guerra rusa que
acedia ocra nia y los países miembros se
comprometieron a dar un paquete de apoyo
integral a largo plazo para que quieren
frente a la agresión de moscú
juntos estamos desplegando más activos
con todos nuestros socios en todos los
dominios por tierra aire agua virtual y
por el espacio estamos reafirmando que
nuestro compromiso es sagrado y el
ataque a uno de nosotros es un ataque a
todos y por eso defenderemos cada
centímetro del territorio de la otan
la región de lindo pacífico será la
nueva vía estratégica de la otan para
frenar ambiciones políticas económicas y
militares de china un país que ahora
representa un reto para los miembros de
la alianza en una zona geoestratégica
que incluso ya se habían planteado como
objetivo eeuu australia y reino unido-
con el pacto august en septiembre del
año pasado la colaboración en el indo
pacífico incluirá nuevas tecnologías
para la ciberdefensa seguridad marítima
y la lucha contra la desinformación
china está aumentando sustancialmente
sus fuerzas militares incluidas las
armas nucleares intimidando a sus
vecinos y amenazando a taiwán vigilando
y controlando a sus propios ciudadanos
mediante tecnología avanzada y
difundiendo mentiras y desinformación
rusa los jefes de estado y de gobierno
dejaron claro que la crisis económica y
alimentaria que afecta a varios países
no es a causa de las sanciones
occidentales sino por los bloqueos de
rusia a los puertos ucranianos y
aseguraron que aunque apoyan a ucrania y
cada centímetro del territorio de la
otan la alianza habilitarlo hace parte
del conflicto
fernando la impresión que tiene uno en
el mundo occidental es que la otan sale
muy fortalecida de este encuentro en
madrid es cierto esto está tan
fortalecida como se ven de occidente y
si esta fortaleza es un error de cálculo
de rusia con esta guerra en ucrania no
pensaban que la alianza se fuera a
fortalecer de esta manera como lo ve
usted
bueno evidentemente es un error del
cálculo por parte de rusia porque sus
informes de inteligencia hablaban de
otras derivadas
militares en cuanto al compromiso por
parte de la unión europea lo que es es
una declaración explícita de un abandono
de lo que es la potencia militar
independiente de europa lo que llamamos
el euro ejército y volver otra vez a la
época de los años 40-50 los que vienen
dependencia militar absoluta y los
intereses geopolíticos eeuu el indo
pacífico con el precio comprado de la
expresión a nuestro no se ha perdido
absolutamente nada en lindo pacífico se
le ha perdido a gran bretaña perdido a
eeuu se pierde australia pero no se le
pierde alemania a francia españa italia
no se pierde nada allí pero sin embargo
somos implicados y por otro lado el
error estratégico que ha sido un
beneficio para nosotros es que las
visiones que tenía turquía sobre suecia
derivan en que primero están los
intereses geopolíticos y luego los
intereses democráticos
era el lugar donde los
kurdos que eran exiliados políticos y
que para gran cara eran eran terroristas
ya no van a ser o debería no puede estar
allí como refugiados se van a ser
entregados directamente a turquía bajo
petición internacional por tanto prima
los derechos económicos y geopolíticos
sobre la democracia y los intereses de
derechos humanos sabemos lo que turquía
va a hacer y algo muy importante que la
gente no está comprendiendo en la unión
de suecia a la otan es un unión muy
particular primero no acepta energía
nuclear el armamento nuclear en su
territorio segundo no acepta bajo ningún
concepto bases permanentes de la otan y
tercero y más importante no aceptará
nunca que haya según el mandato que
ellos quieren no habrá nunca mandato de
la otan no sueco sobre tropas que estén
en suecia decir las tropas temporales
que estén en suecia de la otan
rotatorias siempre han de estar bajo el
mandato de suecia por tanto es una unión
un poco expresión poco rara y está
levantando muchísimas ampollas en los
balcanes gente que lleva
europea y en la otan mucho tiempo y
ahora sin embargo ven que se le pasan un
sorpasso o por parte de estos países
claro y ahí hay conflictos yo creo que
haber conflictos porque las cosas no
están nada claras uno de los reclamos
viene precisamente de ucrania el
presidente de lenski dijo bueno queremos
entrar a la otan y para cuando puede ser
nuestra incorporación vamos a analizar
ese punto y antes le quiero preguntar a
anna sobre precisamente esos dos nuevos
integrantes que fueron invitados después
de este rifirrafe con ankara si algo no
queríamos q era tener fronteras de la
otan cerca ahora va a tener nada más y
nada menos que 1.300 kilómetros de
frontera con la otan por esa frontera
común que tiene con finlandia un país
con el que también tiene un nexo
histórico en el pasado finlandia fue
parte del imperio ruso
anna su opinión sobre la incorporación
de estos dos países
bueno me hace gracia
fue parte del imperio ruso a ver rusia
invadió
en la segunda guerra mundial se quedó
con el 10% del terreno del territorio
finlandés
que es lo que va a hacer ahora con
ucrania
si no quiere que el esquí clases
de cine bien pero vamos no sé
estamos estamos incorporando vamos a
pasar de 30 a 32 miembros de la otan que
van a aportar dinero van a aportar
tropas con las que ya tenemos
entrenamiento ya han participado en
maniobras y lippi de una calidad
excelente ha participado en misiones de
cascos azules muchísimo antes que españa
y luego además
tienen experiencia en el armamento de
última generación o sea que no estamos
no estamos aceptando a cualquiera esto
quiero dejarlo bien claro es la élite de
la élite y luego en una zona estratégica
muy importante porque está además al
lado de los países bálticos que yo estoy
mirando de reojo la amenaza que yo ya
llevo anunciando desde hace tiempo y que
la repito porque ya he dicho ya ha dicho
ayer que me ha dicho también putin que
después que no sale
de rusia van a pasar a sus amigos de
bielorrusia para saltar aleta lituania y
de ahí
estar con con su
pequeña pequeña y pequeña zona de
kaliningrado y entonces nos viene súper
bien tener a suecia y finlandia pero que
no va a ser ni hoy ni mañana que tiene
su proceso es decir ahora tiene que ir
al parlamento aquí tienes un proceso
claro entonces en cuanto a los del halo
de erdogán y la negociación y tal yo
estuve en la rueda de prensa de andy y
erdogán y
va a haber erdogán
empezamos por un que iban a ser 16
por muy puntual porque ya me quedan
pocos minutos para finalizar el programa
por favor vale perdona pidió 16 y 16
paso se han llevado a 73 es decir 73
miembros del pkk
supuestamente de terroristas que habían
participado en 2014 en el intento del
golpe de estado es decir que después voy
a decir que erdogán pedía 180 ciento
166 y se lleva a
sly 283
bueno
fernando cual puede ser entonces la
respuesta rusa a este tipo de
incorporaciones a estas medidas hasta
despliegue de tropas adicionales en los
países bálticos a reforzar la presencia
en cuanto a infraestructura militar en
polonia
ellos han dicho que no ven ningún
problema en que suecia y finlandia
entren en la alianza pero cuál puede ser
la respuesta rusa
la respuesta rusa ya se publicó por
parte del kremlin por parte de putin en
la conferencia ahora en torno a unos
seis meses justo un poquito después de
la invasión dijo que él hacía lo que
hacía para proteger su zona estrategia
su cinturón de seguridad con el donbass
e incorporación de ucrania momento nadie
nadie es el salto puede pensar que putin
quisiera invadir ucrania para lo cual
hace falta casi un millón de personas me
dieron de soldados más el reemplazo no
lo quiero hacer lo que ha hecho es
controlar un territorio bombardeándolo
con misiles de última precisión y
someter a el miedo a ucrania que se
había engañado diciendo que estaría en
europea y la otan lo que va a hacer
rusia lo que haya dicho que rusia es
plantearse ir hasta transnistria que
tiene 24 mil cabezas de misiles y es una
escisión de república moldava y por
tanto muy peligroso cerraría el cerco y
dejaría a ucrania sin ningún tipo de
salida al mar y segundo lo que va a
hacer es en el enclave de kaliningrado
reforzarlo militarmente si entra ve que
suyo por tanto si bien es catedrática te
gadis un cae bajo la jurisdicción de
dinamarca
lo que se declara en grado entraría en
capacidad ofensiva de todos los que es
los países bálticos yo no creo que a
invadir los países bálticos porque
cuando le preguntas a los finlandeses a
los bálticos que tienen miedo por la
mañana ellos y siempre dicen invasión de
rusia y cuando le preguntas al ruso a
que tiene por la mañana de miedo es que
la otan avance un poco más por tanto hay
que ver las dos retóricas las dos
narrativas y comprobar cuál de las dos
no son verdad con ninguna es verdad
cuando las dos mantener un peso
específico y rusia no se va a quedar
fernando rápidamente hablábamos del tema
de ucrania el reclamo que hizo el
presidente es el ens que de esa futura o
posible incorporación a la otan es
viable es posible esa incorporación como
lo vio usted
los 35-40 años no no es posible la
perspectiva sobre esa posible
incorporación ese reclamo hecho por kiev
pues muy rápido
establece que un país que está en
conflicto con otro país no puede
incorporarse hasta que no resuelva ese
conflicto con consiguiente ucrania hasta
que no resolverá el problema ya no puede
no puede incorporarse bueno pues vamos
para las conclusiones me quedan dos
minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero dejar este espacio entonces para
para analizar y para cerrar lo que
significaron estas dos cumbres allí en
europa para mostrar el mundo occidental
como aparentemente está muy unido para
enfrentar a rusia también eeuu tratando
de mantener ese papel de liderazgo
internacional que tan protagonista pudo
haber sido eeuu europa otra vez como lo
decía fernando pues muy a la merced de
lo que pueda decidir washington en torno
a la defensa y en torno a las decisiones
que toma frente a china ya rusia
conclusiones sana
sobre su tirada del cid a oriente siente
que si la presión que esta presión
que ha sido sometida es una presión su
artista sin precedentes y que acelera la
unificación con bielorrusia y desde ahí
ya como primos hermanos ya es la
potencia es una bomba en potencia no es
la otan estado muerta y putin nos ha
hecho un favor a todos porque ha
revivido ha estado tan muerta no es
esa la razón de ser claro fernando un
minuto para la conclusión para el cierre
adelante
la otan estaba muerta una ciudadana y
para beneficio exclusivo de eeuu la otan
ha revivido gracias al apoyo a eeuu y a
sus beneficios geopolíticos no a los
beneficios de europa sino una vez más en
europa perdida si la mano del 'tío sam'
esto suena muy fuerte lo siento pero es
así y el que volvemos a quedar
supeditados los más importantes que el
tablero geopolítico está cambiando eeuu
lucha denodadamente por no quedarse el
segundo o el tercero en la digamos
liderazgo mundial ya económicamente aún
con europa lo va a perder porque el
poderío de china y rúsia antón áfrica
como en latinoamérica es creciente ya va
a perder indo-pacífico lo va a perder
por eso está el tema de taiwán etcétera
etcétera y china va a superar eeuu que
hacía tres años por tanto la otan es
importante la reuniones han sido para
fortalecer a la otan y veremos lo que
ocurre en el futuro por lo menos son los
segundos se coexistir en un bloque
independiente pues a fernando ya ana les
agradezco por este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 ustedes pueden
seguir dejando estos comenta y preguntas
en las redes sociales y pueden seguir
disfrutando de la programación de france
24 siga con nosotros
[Música]